Ukrainians have taken to the streets
with arms to defend their country
and their freedom.
They have prepared Molotov cocktails
as makeshift bombs.
The threat of tyranny isn't only
present in the Third World.
In the United States, critics of the
Second Amendment have claimed
that in modern warfare, small
time weapons are useless
as a check on the power of standing
armies.
The Tree of Liberty is not water in
the blood of patriots.
What's happened is that there
never been. If you want to think you
need to have weapons to take
on the government, you need F-15s
and maybe some nuclear weapons.
But now Biden is sending small
arms to Ukraine's front line
defenders, and it turns out that
weapons of all sorts can
help fight off even a nuclear power.
Ukrainian President Volodymyr
Zelenskyy tweeted he'll give
weapons to anyone who wants
to defend their country.
Ukraine is the only European
nation where firearms are
not regulated by a statute.
Even in peacetime, they were
allowed to carry not fully automatic
rifles and shotguns as
long as they were stored when
not in use.
Ban assault weapons and high
capacity magazines over 100 rounds.
You think the deer wearing Kevlar
vest?
No, but unfortunately, hunting
isn't the only purpose of a gun.
Horrific war in Ukraine
reminds us that the right
to bear arms is still
a check on tyranny.